So, in summary what we have done is we have taken a mechanism, that is
typically used in distributed systems, namely RPC, and
we ask the question suppose we want to
use RPC as a structuring mechanism in a
multiprocessor. How to make that efficient so that
the designers of services will in fact use
RPC as a vehicle. For building these services.
And the reason why you want to promote that, is
because when you put every service in its own protection
domain you are building safety into the system. And that
is very important for the integrity of an operating system.
As an operating system designer, we worry about the integrity
of services and we can provide the integrity by putting
every service in its own protection domain. And we're making
RPC cheap enough that you would use as a structuring
mechanism we are promiting a, a software engineering practice
of building services in sep, in sepearate protection domains.